hello everyone and welcome back to the
Women's World Chase championship match
between Jew engine and late in Jane and
uh so far it's been uh well it's not
been a bloodbath but there were some uh
trading of blows uh in around five dual
engine uh lost again uh late in J2 the
lead and then uh June retaliated in
round date and this is now game 12. uh
so if this one ends in a drawn then we
go into tie break so let's check it out
it's quite a game uh and let's see if we
did get a new world Women's Champion or
uh does Jew engine retain her title so
Pawn to D4 uh Pawn to D5 Knight F3
Knight to F6 and now Pawn to E3 going
for the call system we have won the C5
and now already uh here you will see
something like c3c for Bishop D2 but the
D countries on C5 is incredibly rare
it's uh pretty much no one plays it
except one player alereza firozja plays
this and he plays it with a great
success he defeated some great players
like Fabiano Cortana Wesley so he
defeated kariakin so it can definitely
be played and now it has been played in
a worldshire championship match so here
we have pawned the E6 preparing to take
back the pawn and now Pawn to B4 as you
guys know that it's always very
important to play it as early as
possible we have pawned the A5
challenging the uh the the pawn
defending C5 and now C3 we have
characters captures and now B6 further
undermining white spawn structure here
with Bishop to B5 with check and now you
have to block with the bishop if you
block with the Knight then you allow C6
the game is basically over so after
Bishop to B5 check Bishop to D7 uh was
played and now the ship captures we have
Knight B captures on D7 and now Pawn to
A4 if you're wondering about C6 now it's
not possible unfortunately before
a Jew engine as Bishop captures on B4
ruins uh all of her plans and then let's
say Bishop but the two Bishop captures
queen or Knight captures Knight B8 goes
after the pawn and yes you can defend
the pawn but after Queen C7 the pawn
will fall so it's not possible we have
Pawn to A4 now comes B captures on C5
and now Pawn to B5 you give back the
pawn and now you have uh two connected
fast pawns the a pawn and the V Pawn
whereas black has a past C Pawn so uh
here Bishop to D6 is a known move uh
it's I I think it's also from the game
that uh uh it's not from the game
already played but it also could be yeah
I could just check real quickly I don't
want to trick you guys yeah it actually
is from the game alireza versus Wesley
so uh where Wesley played Bishop to D6
but here we have Queen to C7 and it is
not as of move 11 that we have a
completely new game so okay uh Bishop to
B2 uh the bishop definitely belongs it
belongs on this long diagonal but you
could also make a case for bringing the
bishop over to D2 to help out with the
advancement of the past pawns so Bishop
to D6 we have Castles by both of them
and now Knight B to D2 Rook F to C8 and
now Queen to C2 so of course
um uh juvenile wants to make
preparations to start advancing the past
A and B Pawn and letting J will of
course want to prevent that and start
advancing her own past C Pawn so Pawn to
C4 and now the bishop to C3 stopping uh
further advancement and also not
preparing to push in B pawns uh Knight
to C5 as the square has now been vacated
uh when C4 was pushed and now you you're
looking at Knight to D3 but also Knights
the B3 all depending on what the Jew
engine plays Ponte A5 and now we have
Knight the B3 also Knight to D3 looks
very strong but nice the B3 uh comes
with some threats as The Rook here is
hanging and the real question is uh can
you can you play Bishop captures on F6
so of course you cannot capture here in
the win a pawn because then your Bishop
hangs but uh the real question is is
Bishop captures on F6 something that you
want to do or should you just play Rook
to A2 so you know it's definitely uh a
personal preference someone would prefer
Rook day two someone would prefer to
give up uh the roof for the two pieces
uh Julian should win Bishop captures on
F6 and okay Knight characters on A1
grabbing The Rook Bishop captures on A1
and now also Queen captures on A5 so two
pieces for The Rook nut and maybe the
best of deals but two pieces for a rook
and the pawn a very very much different
because now it's the the past B Pawn
which likely will not survive and then
you will have to worry about elating
Jay's past C Pawn so Queen to C3
offering a queen trade right away and a
Latin J obliges with Queen captures
Bishop captures and now Rook C to B8
going after the past B Pawn Knights to
D4 defending the pawn and here
uh lighting perhaps rushed it a little
bit
um uh here you should consider someone
who's like Rook date or maybe bishop to
C5 uh but she played Pawn to E5 which
comes with a very straightforward idea
get rid of the Knight and pick up the
the past B Pawn but it also allows this
Knight in this beautiful Knight the F5
move and okay now the bishop is hanging
so you don't have time to pick up the
pawn uh Bishop to f8 and now Bishop
captures on E5 attacking and uh grabbing
the pawn while attacking Rook captures
on B5 and now Pawn to G4 and now it's a
much much different game uh maybe the B5
Pawn could have been captured without
giving up this E5 Pawn but okay Pawn to
G6 uh getting rid of the Knight Knight
the D4 attacks the rook and now Rook the
B2 we have Knights the B1 you have to
bring the Knight into the game somehow
so Knight B1 probably coming to C3
Bishop to G7 and we have a trade
captures captures and down Knight to C3
and now uh we really enter the end game
it's a rook and two Knights versus two
Rook so basically Rook for for the two
knights also letting J is still up a
pawn she's the only one for the moment
with a past Pawn but it's gonna be very
very hard to get those Knights off of
those squares so Rook to A5 defending
the D5 Pawn but not just Rook to D1
preparing to move this Knight and go
after at the the D5 Pawn uh even you
could capture with rook and Knight but
also you could just maybe bring the
Knight E to then to F4 and then pick up
the pawn pick up the pawn clean so Rook
the B6 and now Knight D to E2 we have
Rook the B3 sorry Rook to B3 and now uh
a king to G2 waiting uh with the captain
D5 uh we have Pawn to H6 and now King to
F3 yeah first brings her King closer to
the action we have Pawn to F6 and now
Rook the C1 now the Knight is defended
and this Knight can now move to F4 to go
after this phone here and while you
could stop that by playing G5 it's
further weakening of the position then I
comes to D4 then the F5 with check and
so on so after this Rook to C1 King F7
we have Knight to F4 and now Pawn to D4
now the the pawn would fall on D5 so you
have to advance it pawn to D4 and E
captures on D4 at least you've ruined
white spawn structure a little bit
instead of one Pawn Island now you
engine has two Pawn islands and maybe
the d-pawn will be a bit weaker but I
mean with those Knights there it's hard
to uh to say Pawn to G5 chases away the
Knight Knight back to E2 with Pawn to F5
G captures and Rook captures an F5 with
check King to E3 and now Pawn to G4
grabbing more squares here in front of
the white king Knight the F4 and now
Rook back to B8 we have Pawn to D5 the
pawn is now marching forward and Rook to
F6 stopping Pawn to D6 we have Rook to
C2 and not allowing any uh activity for
the for the black Rook on the second
Rank and also maybe Shifting The Rook
over to the D file Rook to a 8 and now
Knight to B5 uh we have a rook the B6
now putting pressure on the Knight and
just Knight back to D4 we have rooked
the A3 with check and now King the E4
it's great to have an active King it's
uh sometimes not so great to have a two
active King but uh obviously the king is
uh very active here not too active so
it's perfectly fine Pawn to C3 uh
letting J also finds a way on how to
advance her own pawn and now of course
the the idea is Rook to V2 so how do you
prevent this well there are two ideas
you could you could just play Knights to
D3 and stop Rook B2 or you could play
Knight E2 and then just go after the C3
pawn and uh uh uh uh decides for the
latter we have Rook to B2 as the move
now has been made possible and King to
D3 just defends the rook and the problem
is if you trade a look at this a real
captures Knight captures now you do
whatever doesn't really matter Knight
captures on C3 uh two knights and the
pawn uh for a rook of course the is
completely winning and that pawn will
win the game so she decides not to trade
she goes Rook to B1 and now Knight
captures on C3 Rook to H1 goes after the
H1 but now Pawn to F3 with the Rook
nicely guarding the pawn along the
second rank G captures an F3 Knight
captures and now Rook to F1 with Knight
back to D4 and King the E7 so of course
while the position is objectively
winning uh Jew engine will still have to
work very hard for her meal as this is
if late in Jay loses this uh she loses
the chance to become the world champion
king to C4 uh we have rooked for now
pinning the Knight and Rook to B2 with
Rook to H4 going after the H2 Pawn if
the Rook ever moves uh and now uh we
have rooked the V7 with check we have
King to F6 and now Rook back to V2 just
defending the pawn we have Rook the A8
and now King the C5 now the king wants
to come to C7 and just escort the pawn
to Victory with Rook to H three going
after the Knight Knight seat the B5 with
Rook to E3
uh and pawn to D6 little by little the
pawn advances further King to E5 and now
Knights the C6 with check we have King
to E4 and now Pawn to D7 now d8 is
coming and there is of course nothing
you can do to stop this Rook to D3 was
played but now Knight to D6 with check
checking the king and also preventing
The Rook from guarding that d8 square
King the F4 was played and now just to
Rook to B8 uh Rook to B8 cutting off
this Rooks uh reach to the D a square
and it was in this position on move 62
that uh late engine resigned the game as
there is nothing more to be done here uh
so really really uh tough break for her
uh she played a a very nice uh World
chair championship match uh for those of
you who have been following from the
beginning she defeated some very very
strong players in the candidates
tournament she defeated Animusic
in the finals and then she was able to
qualify for for her world championship
match against juven Jun and she actually
took the lead in game 5 and well if only
she could have drawn all of them until
the end but dual engine retaliated in
game eight and also now won uh Game 12
which makes you and Jun uh well she
retains her title and she stays the
Women's World Champion now for those of
you who enjoy me when I who enjoy when I
finish the games the reason you resign
here is because okay d8 is coming
everyone can see that and okay maybe you
can give a check Rook to C3 check but
now King D4 now both of your Rooks are
hanging and when you defend them uh the
easiest way to win is not even by
advancing the pawn to becoming a queen
right away it's actually Knight to E5
chess is sometimes funny like that you
just take away the square uh so no
checks are possible if this check is
given then The Rook hangs and basically
it's a well made in few moves you don't
even need a queen to win this look at
this a rook The Rook D3 or anything you
go after the ninth here Rook defeated
with check after King to G5 you play d8
and bring a bishop into the game don't
even need a queen check King H5 and Rook
to F5 with a beautiful Checkmate so
sometimes you know when there's a lot of
stuff on the board you're you're looking
at the position and you're you know how
do I win this in 2030 moves when in
reality the uh the end of the game is
much much closer than you think uh but
yeah of course uh Latin Jay did not want
to see this finished on the board she
had enough and she decided to end the
game here he she shook Joe engine's hand
and yeah for those of you who uh have
been following it you can also enjoy the
uh the discussions after the game and
yeah pretty much it I hope you guys
enjoyed it it was a very nicely played
and not not a not a lot of bloodbath but
there there was definitely some blood uh
and uh it I don't think they've um in
all the games they were played aside
from the winning ones game 5 8 and 12.
there were no missed chances there were
maybe possibilities of improving your
position slightly but no one really made
any any huge errors throughout the
entire 12 games so yeah that's the game
I hope you guys enjoyed it big
congratulations to joining on uh
defending her world chess champion title
successfully I would like to thank
bullet just thriller.com
and Rod Hill for her contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the Chess World so thank you all I will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day